[Musica]
come vedete Ho sentito la riflessione è
parte proprio da questo
quando è iniziato il mio percorso di
ricerca nell'arte contemporanea subito
dopo la Accademia quello che mi ha
profondamente incuriosito era tutto
quello che io andavo a gettare nel
cestino dei rifiuti parlo ormai di 30
anni fa e quindi siamo la sensibilità
per quello che era l'ambiente non era
quello di oggi però sicuramente la mia
sfida è stata posso realizzare delle
opere d'arte con quello che
effettivamente era nel mio cestino dei
rifiuti quello che noi troviamo
all'interno di questo cestino questo
baluginare di luce questa bellezza Alla
fine poi trasformarsi in quello che
riteniamo
Massimo valore Come può essere d'arte
contemporanea e diciamo da questa
riflessione è partita la mia ricerca mi
sono interessata da subito ai materiali
plastici proprio perché oltre alla loro
criticità sappiamo che una bottiglia di
plastica oggi viene degradabile Siamo
qui a una decomposizione più veloce ma
la classica di alcuni anni fa aveva
quasi un milione di anni per poter
essere reinserito nell'ambiente e quindi
questa da una parte era la sfida e
quindi l'idea di occuparmi di un rifiuto
ma dall'altra era Ma questo materiale è
fantastico
In effetti quando
ci avviciniamo prendiamo la nostra carta
di credito nessuno di noi si scandalizza
che fatta di plastica quando invece lo
vediamo Appunto una bottiglietta
abbandonata Cominciamo a pensare Beh
forse bisognerebbe ipotizzare degli
altri materiali e quindi anche questo
materiale in sé Ha una grandissima
complessità ha portato tantissimo
benessere nelle nostre case negli anni
sessanta e devo dire che io ogni volta
che mi avvicino una bottiglia colorata
intravedo anche del vetro di Murano come
vedete Anche qui c'è questa luce questa
bellezza che può dare delle risposte
e così è nato sono nati i miei lavori
sono nati appunto raccogliendo prima i
rifiuti della mia casa miei rifiuti
personali e poi sono nati progetti
collettivi l'idea appunto della Bellezza
parte a volte da una riflessione della
storia come vedete
nella slide c'è un frammento di un
mosaico della cattedrale di Salerno e
questo è un progetto
all'interno di via Mercanti proprio
all'interno della città quindi occuparsi
di ambienti occuparsi di arte forse
occuparsi anche di comunicare alla
comunità e per questo non per forza
dentro un museo ma anche nelle vie e
quindi installazioni pubbliche
trasformarlo all'estremo come vedete in
questi pannelli in cui le bottiglie
stesse non sono più riconoscibili e
stanno proprio su questo crinale tra
rifiuto ma nello stesso tempo seduzione
vedete anche in questo caso il lavoro
assemblato con elementi modulari questi
appunto sono fondi di bottiglia possono
trasformarsi davvero come dicevo in
momenti di comunità pensate a questo
edificio e Gallarate un premio storico
che viene dato allora alcuni anni fa ad
artisti Questo era un edificio
abbandonato l'intervento non solo delle
mie classi come all'interno artistico ha
fatto sì che l'intera parte Piazza
diventare rigenerate quindi ha
dato vita a questo spazio per incontri e
per due mesi sono avvenuti
non sono incontri ma anche a concerti ed
eventi e quindi anche qua l'arte che
diventa un meccanismo che fa scaturire
questa bellezza attraverso e qui il
gioco dello start e quindi attraverso
questo materiale a cui nessuno dà valore
qua Vedete un dettaglio e appunto prese
singolarmente le nostre bottiglie sono
proprio queste Io le ho sezionate
assemblate hanno date con dei sacchetti
di plastica tagliati diciamo come delle
piccole stringhe per trasformarle in un
grande abito Questo è un progetto
didattico nato nel 99 per il Castello di
Rivoli vicino a Torino ed è una grande
Regina un progetto che era nato proprio
dedicato all'educazione e anche ai
bambini al dipartimento didattico Quindi
vedete anche in questo caso c'è un gioco
davvero dissuntuosità di quello che
tutti noi conosciamo attraverso le
nostre case e tutti noi davvero buttiamo
nel cestino
Ma le bottiglie sono anche il desiderio
di indagare come materiale quindi spesso
mi sono trovata a sezionare quasi fosse
un piccolo chirurgo andare a sezionare
con delle forbici a sminuzzarle e capire
questo materiale oltre appunto ad una
sua bellezza intrinseca che cosa poteva
restituire un materiale che oltre a
essere tagliato si può deformare con il
calore a questa capacità questa
brillantezza cromatica e quindi è nel
mio caso un modo davvero per raccontare
altre storie e sfidarne sempre di più
questo tagliuzzare il frammenti mi ha
pensato mi ha permesso di immaginare
anche la trasformazione in quello che
noi riteniamo nella nostra società di
più prezioso e quindi ha dei gioielli
che vedete appunto nelle immagini ma
anche la possibilità di far dialogare
con questo materiale con dei veri e
propri
materiali che riteniamo di lusso come
per esempio loro
è nata una collaborazione con un'amica
orefice di Valenza e vedete queste
piccole foglioline Gialle sono
foglioline di plastica unite ossidiana e
a questo bracciale di titanio
e la mia domanda era sempre ma quanto
possiamo ritenere Cioè se ha più valore
l'oro o effettivamente la plastica
stessa se pensiamo che oggi la plastica
di seconda generazione ha dei costi
elevatissimi per esempio Appunto quando
vengono compattate e raccolte le nostre
bottiglie Le nostre classiche vengono
rivendute poi a chi oggi utilizza questo
materiale per poter essere rigenerato da
un minimo di 200 euro a salire Quindi
negli anni questo materiale ha cambiato
anche il concetto di valori di nuovo
abbiamo una bivalenza appunto di quello
che noi banalmente consideriamo senza
valore e che poi scopriamo che oggi
all'interno della società acquisisce
davvero un altro livello se parliamo a
livello di economia
e così lo stesso tema
paradossistico di quello che è l'arte
contemporanea Quindi anche un'operazione
artistica fa sì che quell'oggetto
inserito all'interno di un sistema
dell'arte contemporanea cambia valore
questo è un altro installazione
realizzata a Torino Si chiama palle di
neve e
installata appunto dal 98,99 e questo
per esempio è un'opera che ha dato una
grandissima visibilità alla città di
Torino prestata per esempio a Marsiglia
città della cultura e la triste sorte di
questa installazione che quando cambiate
l'amministrazione sei anni fa la città
non aveva più un magazzino dove poter
stoccare questo lavoro ed è stato
buttato al macero Quindi anche qui c'è
un corto circuito di quello che
effettivamente ha un valore se entra
Forse in una collezione privata Ma
quando
come in questo caso è una collezione
pubblica quanto possiamo preoccuparci
oppure come Alla fine
abbiamo per scontato che alcune opere
abbiano valore Proprio perché sono parte
e costituite di materiali più pregevoli
rispetto ad altri e quindi anche questo
è stato uno stranissimo Corto Circuito e
una sorta abbastanza triste per questa
installazione
la plastica Effettivamente è molto
per me molto interessante anche perché
la possibilità Come avete visto prima di
essere indovinata Questo progetto si
chiama fiori della luna era nato a
Trieste molti anni fa nel 2001 per il G8
ed erano queste grandi linee
galleggianti che appunto avevano un
elemento illuminante all'interno e
quindi posizionate sull'acqua creavano
tutto questo gioco di riflesso e di
magia
piuttosto che appunto dovendo sezionare
ritrovarmi con migliaia e migliaia di
Tatti in casa e quindi pensare che
questi tappi potevano diventare un
mosaico realizzato accostando tra loro
questi piccoli frammenti quasi fossero
davvero delle tessere preziose per
andare a costituire delle geometrie
infinite condividendole sempre anche con
la collettività in questo caso ho
realizzato all'interno di una fondazione
anche con un pubblico di studenti
dell'Accademia quindi questo lavorare
anche insieme permette a questo
materiale che noi non diamo
assolutamente valore che oggi sembra
veramente
il problema ecologico permette in realtà
di creare degli altri meccanismi di
valore che sono comunque
con un punto di vista completamente
differente
in questo caso invece il progetto è nato
lo scorso anno per una un'area
periferica di Torino che è Lungo Dora
Napoli un'area di Forte immigrazione
dove In realtà ho lavorato per una
settimana costruendo questi piccoli
elementi illuminanti posizionati sui
balconi e quindi anche in questo caso io
non so qual è il valore se il valore
dell'Opera effettivamente quell'oggetto
che vedete quello esagono o il valore
sono stati quei momenti condivisi
all'interno di questa comunità
e comunque appunto porto Sicuramente nel
mio cuore ma perché è stata
un'esperienza incredibile soprattutto è
stata questa grande complicità che ogni
proprietario di quella di questo
condominio ha potuto posizionare sul
proprio balcone un elemento che
diventava in sé un'operazione Corale
un'opera d'arte condivisa
e poi la didattica con con i bambini
raccontare cos'è la plastica ma
soprattutto condividere con loro la
scoperta di questo materiale ma anche la
scoperta delle forme dei colori di poter
assemblare delle storie delle fiabe
davvero con cose che appartengono a
tutti noi e a tutta la nostra
quotidianità e all'interno di questo
scarto non c'è una una strada definita
ma può essere un ricciolo di plastica un
piccolo nodo un fiocco di neve però è
proprio sperimentando che nascono
appunto questi questi momenti emozionali
dati dai rifiuti
questo percorso diciamo di ricerca mi ha
permesso anche di lavorare su questa
idea di condivisione ma anche di
recupero di uno spazio inizialmente uno
spazio che è nato da aver fondato
un'associazione che asilo bianco
situato appunto sulle colline del Lago
d'Orta in Piemonte e che ha una sua
dimensione Molto dinamica e fluida per
la valorizzazione del territorio Quindi
non si parla più di plastica ma si parla
ancora di comunità Quindi forse la
plastica è davvero una diciamo uno
strumento che mi permette di muovermi
Anche quando
si interviene all'interno di alcune aree
come in questo caso aree collinari che
avevano una forte criticità con il
spopolamento piccoli Borghi abbandonati
ed è nata questa associazione che da 18
anni realizza tutta una serie di
attività e che adesso
vedete questo spazio è proprio nel
Piccolo Borgo di Orta San Giulio uno
spazio abbandonato però
ho intuito e spero di di così che potrò
un domani di poter condividere con noi a
fortissimo e potenzialità e quindi alla
fine l'arte mi permette anche di fare un
ulteriore slittamento di senso per
affrontare quello che non solo sono
Comunità ma anche spazi e migliaia di
spazi che conosciamo tutti noi nelle
nostre centri storici e potersi occupare
anche di questo
e quindi concludo Vabbè Ringraziandovi
lasciando questo segno Questa bandiera
che spero di posizionare al più presto
al di fuori di questo di questo spazio
appunto in questo piccolo centro storico
uguale a migliaia di centri storici in
Italia e che possa sventolare con questi
colori cangianti fatti di sacchetti di
plastica ma ti appartengono un po' a
tutta la nostra storia Grazie
[Musica]